it's in five states they don't know if
it's a virus or our micro they don't
know but it's spread you need to build
people are killing you need to spend
less time online okay the authorities
would tell us hi I'm Robert Kirkland
welcome to the set of fear The Walking
Dead fear The Walking Dead is an
entirely new original concept created by
Robert Kirkman and our showrunner Dave
Erickson the audience coming to the show
because there are so many die-hard fans
you expect a certain thing in The
Walking Dead we want to give that sense
and then pull the rug out from under
them I think the coolest thing about
this show is that it tells its own story
you don't need to have watched The
Walking Dead to understand fear The
Walking Dead this is a new and exciting
twist we're in Los Angeles so it's got a
completely different vibe a completely
different feel as far as the timeline
goes we're pushing things back we're
gonna be dealing with the initial start
of the outbreak there's so much more
story by way of the zombie world that
has to come it's incredibly dynamic it's
incredibly action driven we've worked
very very hard to give it its own
identity but keep it true to the Walking
Dead world that we've created send me a
very close show
hey youtubers it's Charlie so a bunch of
new stuff from fear The Walking Dead's
this is gonna be a breakdown of the new
footage as well as what's going on with
the series there's still a bunch of
questions that they haven't answered yet
I've also got a really cool announcement
that I'll do at the end of the video so
here we go so apparently there's no big
thing to worry about
no Walker virus that's gonna take over
the entire world everybody just chill
out for about six months till the Walker
[ __ ] hits the fan somebody be sure to
check and make sure that Rick's door
still locked in that Hospital the person
we see in the trailer she was one of the
main stars that's Kim Dickens you've
probably seen her and at least something
before she shows up all over the place
she was on sons of anarchy she was in
house of cards let's have all the cast
members of they've announced for the
show she's the one that's maybe most
excited this first season is gonna be
the descendant of madness so in the
timeline of the main show I would say
this is some time maybe a month or two
before Rick goes into a coma Robert
Kirkman is always kind of fuzzy about
exact dates but you know generally
speaking this takes place while Rick is
in a coma remember he got shot went to
the hospital when everything was still
fine or I should say before everyone
knew that something was bad because the
virus spread over the world almost
instantaneously I would I would say that
definitely started before he went into
the coma which is the people didn't
start noticing it because you don't turn
into a walker unless you die it's like
the snowball effect you know where one
Walker makes two walkers those two make
four walkers and so on and so on so all
the people you'll meet in Episode one
will be in complete denial the kid that
we stopped running in the last promo we
I mean we didn't see what he was running
from that's actually that's this
character's son she along with Cliff
Curtis or like like the two main leads
they both have families of their own and
they they kind of band together as the
[ __ ] hits the fan and if any of the
other promos haven't made it clear this
is taking place in Los Angeles that the
people are here already kind of like
walkers so it fits really well just a
bunch of really rich zombies just
shuffling around Beverly Hills
I feel like this kid is gonna end up
being the Lisa Simpson of the series
like the smart person that nobody
listens to that's the curse of being
smart in a post-apocalyptic world it's
like the smarter you are the less people
will listen to you but you can't be too
hard on him I mean you remember what
Carroll was like before the apocalypse
now she actually Melissa McBride just
won a Saturn Award for the second year
in a row for her portrayal of Carol a
lot of you have been
you know what does this have to do with
the comics Robert Kirkman said that they
created this to be something separate
from the comics the main series is
adapted directly from the comics that
you know they take stories directly from
the comics and turn them into scripts
well for the most part I mean it's an
adaptation so they have to change things
to fit with the cast that they have the
spin-off series is gonna be just a
completely different group of characters
than we've seen in the comics they're
just like so many other stories that you
could tell in The Walking Dead universe
but we've been so localized to Georgia
that it's like okay we want to go over
to the other side of the United States
don't counter some of the same
challenges just make completely
different choices like choose your own
adventure with walkers the really
important stuff though they've only said
that it's gonna premiere in August they
haven't set a specific date yet which is
kind of mysterious usually they just
think they say like it's gonna air on X
Day it's either gonna be the 23rd or the
30th they're gonna air all six episodes
in season one that's right it only has
six episodes and then like the week
after that they'll air season 6 episode
1 or you know maybe the same week it
depends on how they're gonna time it
they might take a break somewhere in the
middle or they might air them
consecutively essentially they're gonna
be marketing the [ __ ] out of the
spin-off series and they want to
dovetail that with the main series
season six isn't gonna premiere to that
second week in October it's gonna be the
same week it is every year it's always
that second Sunday but if you remember
way way back there were only six
episodes of the main series in season
one that was just because they wanted to
see how the show was gonna do it's so
expensive to produce that they didn't
want to buy like 20 episodes and have it
tanked obviously that didn't happen it
became super popular it's more popular
it gets higher ratings than Game of
Thrones to give you a perspective they
have listed a second season of the
spin-off show but I don't know that
that's confirmed yet but if they do
renew it then it would probably get a
full series order so we get 16 episodes
of that - or at least 13 The Walking
Dead is an exception amongst other AMC
shows and that it gives a couple extra
episodes per season just because it's so
profitable for them Robert Kirkman said
that the general idea is is that the
timeline of the spin-off series would
catch up with the main show but this
first season is going to tell this story
of the outbreak so by episode 6 we will
definitely see a ton of walkers chasing
people down but they won't be quite as
decomposed
as the walkers of the main show because
remember just a whole lot more time is
passed that's always the big question
that people have it's like how come
there's so many walkers still walking
around if they're not eating anybody
it's not like they gain mass when they
eat people logically you know eventually
their organic tissues would just break
down until they were just pure skeletons
and they just crumpled into a pile of
bones
maybe we'll see that when we get to
Walking Dead Season 17
everyone's always wondering you know how
many seasons The Walking Dead is gonna
go that's also part of the reason for
the spin-off series because it's like
they can get maybe like five or six
seasons at least out of that probably
seven but the main show is gonna be too
expensive to produce by the time it gets
past season ten and I have no idea if
it's gonna go that long I think AMC is
gonna do everything they can to keep it
around but a lot of that will fall on
Robert Kirkman and the producers you
know if they think they can keep writing
fresh stories if it's any indication
Robert Kirkman has said that he won't
stop writing the comic book until people
stop buying it which is never so that
means that the TV show will have stories
to adapt indefinitely but I'm really
excited for it to come back they're just
they're not a lot of dramas that match
the level of Game of Thrones WTF usually
I try to have like a couple shows to
balance out my week you know shows it
are a little bit lighter a little bit
funnier then you have like the crazier
stuff like Game of Thrones and Walking
Dead you get the whole spectrum of WTF
really it's the task of this spin-off
series to be just as thrilling as The
Walking Dead without going straight to
Walker's although I don't think they
would have pitched the series if there
wasn't going to be a walker like
something identifiable as The Walking
Dead by the end of that first episode
here's my big question for you guys do
you think that they're going to have
like a child like a little girl Walker
like they did in the first episode of
The Walking Dead series where Andrew
Lincoln goes up Indians up having to
kill that little girl Kim Dickens just
sees like some little girl in the middle
of the road and she has to run over with
her car or something crazy what's gonna
happen at comic-con is they're actually
they're being both shows are doing like
a two-hour panel I don't know what kind
of footage they're gonna air whatever it
is I'll do a video for it also post the
panel's so we'll all be good the way the
schedule is breaking down at comic-con
right now it seems like it's gonna be a
lighter year than last year they're just
like a couple big film companies like
Marvel paramount Sony that aren't going
there are a couple big TV panels that
aren't happening because shows having
star
shooting new footage yet so there aren't
a lot of trailers to be shown somehow I
think I'm gonna wind up standing in a
bunch of lines anyway though if you've
never been to comic-con it's a lot of
standing in line but it is still a lot
of fun it's kind of like being a walker
you got to like experience the herd at
least once in your life but comic-con in
general can be kind of a [ __ ] show if
you're not prepared for it so what's
gonna happen is is because there's a
bunch of other Walking Dead Season 6
stuff I'm gonna do a separate video for
that I'll just I'll post it next on
Saturday there were a couple other
videos that I announced in the Supergirl
trailer I just posted if you haven't
seen that just just watch that and it
explains some of the next videos that
might be working on and I've also been
posting it to my game channel recently
too so if you don't know about the game
channel there's a link for that in the
description so a big announcement after
we get through comic-con I'm gonna be
working with Skybound to try and find
something really cool to do with you
guys it might be a giveaway it might be
something else as long as there aren't
any contracts to prevent me from telling
you guys about it ahead of time I will
be sure to keep you guys updated I'm
also actually trying to do the same
thing for a game of Thrones
although HBO doesn't handle all the
merchandising for Song of Ice and Fire
like Random House does the books I mean
this is a bunch of stuff so hopefully
the giveaways that I do every week will
start getting cooler and cooler that's
definitely the goal what good is a giant
YouTube channel if you can't give a
bunch of really awesome free [ __ ] away
so don't forget new Walking Dead Season
6 stuff coming next
that'll be Saturday morning depending on
where you guys live I'm Pacific time
what you guys wait for that you can
click here for the last Walking Dead
trailer and you can click here for my
Game of Thrones Q&A from this week thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tomorrow